The second kind of connector we'd like to look at are event connectors these
are, these are also very common. In fact [INAUDIBLE] book on the resource page.
They devote a very nice section to describing all the different variations that
might exist with event connectors.
First of all event connectors are responsible for a flow of controls so
that's a coordination role. They may also pass parameters. Typically this
might involve time stamps, or actual data, so that's a communication wall.
Event connectors, once an event is detected, generate messages, method calls.
After detecting the event or some combination of events that it's,
it's prepared to detect. Event connectors are particularly relevant for
distributed, asynchronous applications in which we need to know when certain
things happen. The set of event connectors that exist is dynamic.
That is, the application itself can turn on or
turn off the ability to detect certain events. Some of the variations that might
exist among implementations of event connectors include cardinality.
That is how many different components can produce the event? How many different
observers of the event might exist? And might there be patterns of events?
In which, we like to be able to detect currents of the pattern.
How were the events actually communicated? Is it via best effort, exactly once,
at most once, at least once? Do we have a priority among a set of events?
Do we always handle the outgoing ones before the incoming ones?
Are there different priorities embedded with the event that are handled in
a certain fashion? Synchronous, asynchronous, or based upon certain time out?
How is notification handled? Is it polled? That is,
does the potential receivers have to periodically look to see whether the event
occurred? Is there a published, published subscribe interface in which
a particular component registers it's interests in events. And then, gets told
when events happen? Is there a central updating mechanism that, a registry that
receives all of the events and distributes them to the known, known parties. Or
is, are there queues sitting there that everybody's responsible for
looking at. Causality refers to the circumstances determining the actual
issuing of the events. Are there, absolute, absolute event occurrences?
Or, could could the events be relative to other situations that
is conditional type events. And what's is the ultimate, generator of the event.
Might it come from hardware such as pa, page faults, interrupts, or traps. Or
are they software signals or triggers or even, inputs from the, from the GUI.